foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
hello
people
there we go
we have new emotes
new emotes new emotes new emotes woo
and new overlays obviously
foreign
holy text chat
I didn't think it was that big
hold on I gotta do something what's up
people how we doing today
the dog emote
yeah this one
boom it's the pope peeking over corner
we have cheese it's not grilled cheese
but it's cheese
good morning coach
we have Maiden Maiden
we got pot boy hello
bum bum okay hold on let me actually do
the thing I said I was about to do and
then I didn't do it
good morning good evening good afternoon
wherever you're from
welcome
bomb
I want to make sure this chat looks good
[Music]
it's a little big
it's a little big
let's go with like a font size of
that
maybe a bit smaller
happy
ball
there
yeah hopefully have everyone's having a
great day so far
see if this works
they're beautiful
they're beautiful
I really like them I think they're cute
that didn't work why not
I have to launch it
okay there we go
copy
uh delete
paste
press ok
refresh
why is this not working
oh wait
okay now we're good
I'm scrolled down slightly sorry that's
why
why did the size not increase at all
hello
sorry
the only way I can test doing this
is uh
by having chat so I have to do it at the
start of stream sorry
keep typing there we go now that's
bigger that's much bigger
that'll probably do let me do that
actually
okay sorry I'm very particular about
this
I apologize it's dab time
about to steal my mom's credit card to
become a member I mean you get these
cool ass emotes now dude so hey
yeah it should be fun all right let's do
it
I want to go right into it man let's go
I want to beat this today potentially
depending on the freaking bosses we get
actually
I think that's a
pretty major test to get this done today
I don't think we can might take a couple
more times
gonna watch on your iPad let's freaking
go
brick yeah iPad
I want to be daytime I don't like night
time
we've been rocking this helmet the
entire time you should put this on
Twitch no I don't like twitch very much
yep we clip through the helmet so we can
go into the capital city now by the way
we have we have acquired two great runes
we could try one thing I wanted to do
was do Ronnie's questline
so that we can see what's on her bridge
I think is right here the carrion Bridge
right here
we can see what's in the carrion Manor
as well
and fight that boss talk to Ronnie
we get some bosses out of that and then
we can see what's up here at the end of
her quest line
so I think we should do that
let's do that first let's go to EG
what happened yesterday
um I couldn't even tell you everything
that happened
it's a lot
just go re-watch it when you have the
time it's on
it's on the channel
fully uploaded
we have not found radon however Reichard
stage one was at the festival
in caled
we have not found radon yet
we have fought both versions of the fire
Giant
in two different areas
very interesting
okay we got a big boy crab we have a
fire boy where a hand would be
gimme gimme thank you
we are still on the quest to find a
somber 3 which would upgrade us to Plus
10.
we have fought both versions of
reichardt as well that is true holy [ __ ]
I thought that was a somber three and I
was gonna poop my pants
it's just a stupid somber 4.
bro leave me alone please
yeah that area was insane
is this your best armor probably not
that's okay though
you should try the Sakira randomizer
would you guys want us to even like
finish a playthrough
that could be fun
yeah
oh God
oh God
let's go this way
because we started Sakura like a month
ago
see what's down here
yeah let's do one thing at a time
okay what we got oh
man asked me like two months ago
that would be lit
too bad
so sad
let's see what this is
wow
wow oh wow
is that a crabby boy Lobster Boy
keep grabbing things boys
rivers of easy mode
yeah like two months ago it's actually
like still pretty good right to my
understanding
it's not bad
it's not like what it was though
obviously
does this randomize bosses
yes it does uh majorly that's like the
main appeal
was the highest donation you have
received
um on here
because I streamed on Twitch for four
years as well
that hurt
I think the highest donation overall
I've gotten was like a thousand dollars
it's right off the rip
mine went the wrong way oh the finger
seal we'll take that though
we need to go back this way however
stop it
stop it
these dogs are like what the [ __ ] dude
foreign
my God
if you do Ronnie's Quest at the church
you marry her a lot of purple items
that's what I was thinking
why are they blue because they're
normally blue here
I it would really be iconic for this
channel in particular that the
eldenbeast fight would be Rick that
would be amazing
I would cry was that when you streamed
rocket League yes
how can you find the moon ring
I mean that's true we may not even get
the moon ring
from renal
we also need to go down under and and
see what we get from the Finger Slayer
blade area
this may not even be possible
it's not very good
we just gotta see we gotta experiment
[Music]
boom boom
okay we got a bat boy
all right let's see what this boss is up
here
one day we will achieve Sombra 3 Guys
one day
okay
I needed to take a moment
are you kidding me
oh
like I just want to talk to Ronnie bro
that's it
foreign
not terrible oh God
spoke too soon
imagine getting hit by that tiny little
tail
nice
we like this
foreign
as I say that I should shut the [ __ ] up
next time
well this is gonna be weird
hey there he is
oh
I thought he was outside of the arena
for a second
stay stay
this is really cool though
to be fair
all right
did he fall
where you at man
he didn't die though oh
there you are
[ __ ]
God bless it
oh come on man
not fair at all
I can't see I'm dead
I'm somehow alive
die peasant
why is there lightning over here
where am I gonna run if he does the nuke
thing
this is so cool
he killed something over there
come down here
no I knew he was gonna do that too
when have you ever done that attack okay
stop
flying man
he's gonna get stuck
yep
I can see his head
okay there we go
quit running for me
foreign
oh don't kill me
oh I'm dead I'm dead I'm dead I'm dead
this is so cool
yes let's go
okay that was awesome
wow Flintstone comment Shard for that
huh
man that was sick
holy [ __ ]
a lot of these boss fights like that was
obviously extremely glitched out but a
lot of these fights like really look
very interesting in these weird areas
you know
w
ow all right what's gonna be over here
by the way if you're a member I think we
have a GG
it's like a GG easy emote I think
forget which one did I even add that
hold on
yeah yeah yeah yeah it just says GG
like that oh I didn't mean to do the
thingy
that'll work
remember to go east
what do you mean from here
yeah let's go this way
ever jail
oh there's a castle
I don't remember what's over here
something peculiar
stop it
I want to see what this is
excellent
not what we want
radon is a bad boss
imagine
there's a graveyard with a painter
okay we like graveyards just for the uh
items we get
I have not used summons very much
because I don't know like we can't find
the upgrades for them so they're kind of
poo poo
you know what I'm saying
I mean somber 3 we pretty much beat the
game I ain't gonna cap like the game's
over if we get a somber three
[Music]
smithing three
am I missing the area
we should probably check and see if we
have the Bell I'm like I'm avoiding
using summons
um
for people being like
bruh you made this so easy by using
summons
like radon is an L boss
like kind of people like that you know
what I'm saying
you know what I'm talking about
yeah they're extremely annoying let's
see what we got here though
I have an arrow in my abdomen
is this
why do you look weird oh yeah randomizer
this is gonna be weird boys
wrecked
okay physical damage is nuts
oh
[Music]
should have died
it's hard to get him to stand in it
stop rolling
hasn't
where'd my trail go
[ __ ]
he is
aggressive
probably don't need to do that
what is this oh yeah
nice come back over here
excellent
not worth
LOL
[Music]
it's like a PVP fight
oh my [ __ ]
how much FP does vike have
or bro come on
oh yeah okay spam that twice
interesting
yeah it seems like infinite FP
for sure
no it just ran out
420 nice
okay that wasn't awful it was just
annoying actually
oh imagine that's a somber three
imagine that's a somber three
lord of the universe where vike doesn't
fall in becoming Elden Lord
that's the lore of him right what are
you what are you doing
what kind of what kind of summoning
snail are you
you cut that out right now
number three nope
how about you
wow that's kind of weird okay let's go
this way
the all-knowing
yeah talk about infinite FP now they
definitely boosted or buffed Gideon
for sure
try finding the painter
hmm
I don't think it'll be worth it it's
okay
foreign
to become a member work it should
Bang
well welcome R4 good to have you glad
you enjoyed it
they hacked Facebook
oh no not Facebook
does anyone still use Facebook
all right do I fight you
I wonder if he'll Fly Away
foreign
do you think he's gonna disappear
like the normal Dragon that's here
ow
that's fire okay now he's gone he just
he actually just Clips out he's gone
interesting
hahaha
oh no
not a Tarana dog
how about just the normal doggies
all right okay okay Ronnie should look
exactly the same
what's worse Facebook or Twitter I think
it depends on what you mean
oh
here's my take on radon if you think
radon is a bad boss
hmm something funny
I think you're an idiot
oh but you can have your own opinion
[Music]
we already went through the whole
Scarlet rot area
so we don't even have to meet everyone
down below or do we because we can't
teleport anywhere
there's your mommy chat
there's Mommy
I think anyone who doesn't like the
radon boss fight just died to him a lot
and you're salty because of it
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah we've all heard
this
together
okay
blyde no here
in what way is radon a gimmick I see oh
God you must be so this looks weird I
like your hat man
I asked if it were up to but who
okay
[Music]
did you just compare radon to the great
wood tree in Dark Souls 3.
what
all right now I just think you're
trolling
wow
still I look for
and it will be I have a high look
okay
now we can just go below
and go
you wonder if I have to talk to her
this will be remain I think that's what
it is no it's this
nope wrong place
is it here
must be
foreign
you I mean even before he got nerfed you
could still dodge it
it just wasn't as easy as it is now
that's all
okay we don't really need to do that
oh this isn't even the area I want to be
in I want to go here
what am I thinking
that's not what it's called
I'm probably some below the well
I don't think I got the worshiper
ancestral Woods thing yet so I gotta go
here
Melania Ronaldo Ronnie Melina Rodrigo
FIA my list you don't like Thea she
gives you hugs
have you guys ever gotten a hug in a
video game before
foreign
oh I just realized that we yeah we
probably can't even get what we need
like we're gonna open this chest and
it's not gonna be the Finger Slayer
blade
why would you piss off the 12 year old
PV ears
thank you
did you just admit to coming in a chat
room to piss people off
by saying something and nothing else
that's kind of weird
okay okay
not gonna use it but thank you
somber three
nope definitely not
whoops
no
no shoot
what is this
ew
about you
golden roon smithing Stone six
how is it this hard to find a somber 3
Guys
like whoa why what is happening
it's gonna be the best feeling in the
world when it happens though
strength tier I like that I don't think
this guy always gives me yeah the thing
I don't want
let's do this
let's see what we got in her wow
oh you're strong [ __ ] you
yeah after we beat the game we finally
get a somber three
that's the drop
okay
yeah you find remembrances randomly
Everything Is Random
can I go this way
oh I have to jump through a window over
there how do I get over there
I haven't even seen that before
okay I thought that was like a glowy
rock it ain't
okay you should give me something
ballistable
another face weapon Jake will choose to
use choose to ignore yeah
there's a window outside the mimic room
is there actually
that's pretty cool
I gotta go check it
especially now that I see what's in
front of us a rune bear
and a [ __ ] Lobster this is gonna be
great but let's go check it
yeah this weapon does look dumb but it's
one of my favorite weapons in the game
why am I hearing a sparkle
game froze oh that's the thing upstairs
that's right
um
every item would be a glowing item like
the the somber 3 would be a glowing item
if you see a plant it's a plant
so there's a window in here
where
is this not the mimic
room like this is where you'd normally
get the mimic tier
it's bugging again
oh right here thank you
I got you I got you oh
oh I didn't think it was a jump
I just thought it was a normal oh man
I didn't look
the worst part about universities
getting addicted to stupid things
currently battling
I don't know what that is
mimics just green
I died
yeah it's a running jump I thought it'd
just be a ledge I'd fall down onto
Adderall yikes
Adderall sounds so scary to me I've
never tried it
Q
no drop
oh imagine I guess it wouldn't have
glowed blue
if it was gonna be a somber
Adderall is legal meth
I wouldn't know I have no clue
hey what are the chances that they're
like in their mimic form and won't [ __ ]
with me never mind
scratch that
okay
I need to hit that real quick
what are you gonna be
in Regal wow that's a great scepter
like the best in the game we need to run
just keep running run
heal
because I don't think we're beating
anything here
stay
I knew it I [ __ ] knew it okay the
bear got [ __ ] up wow gravel Stone
I'm glad we went here for that
that's amazing gravel Stone
thank you
oh [ __ ] hell
get me out of here
I'm in the I'm in the ground
did you see me
[ __ ] you [ __ ] okay where can we go now
that's legit inside the ground okay
um
little little
hmm
we can go to the city
that is now open
bear was gonna send you the [ __ ]
Shadow realm yeah he was
the vendor in Korea Manor
um oh I can go see the vendor can I
you know we should check that that could
be a that's a bell bearing
and a uh yeah that's that's that's a
good call
good call good call
have a good one scoreboard
Ronnie's treasured gravel Stone
what enemy do you hate the most
um I hate redone
because he because his arrows are too
fast
and
I only look at his crotch the entire
fight
just unbalanced
oh I could have went there I'm going the
wrong way where am I going
uh probably
what enemy do I hate the most
probably the the sacred science is that
what they're called the ones that just
never stop moving
yeah revenants I always forget their
name because I just
try and forget them from my brain
what am I hearing
you don't give me nothing
yeah the virgins are tough too we can go
and try that fight again under the oh
that was loud
under the
radon's Tower
hello you
I am I am I am I am I am I am
I am I am I please please be it
God damn it
I'm buying this for Moog
golden seed obviously
it's a four bro
it's a [ __ ] four man
can I get your bell
can't
Moog is dead so you think
or actually you're right damn it
I thought there could be a potential
like uh
second phase but then I remembered he
did his entire second phase
so never mind that that was a waste of a
thousand or however much it was let's go
over here
that was quite the day when we did that
in epic gamer moment
you could say
okay let's do it
waste of money
yeah I know I just [ __ ] said that
you goober ass
[Music]
I look really cool
don't you think
death root oh we should check grank as
well I wonder if he'll give us anything
I just thought of that
two four pickled foulfits wow
okay
that's different
not what I expected to be in here
oh I ain't dealing with it nope
nope nope nope nope
your head looks like an egg thank you
hi Melina
you're welcome you're welcome
oh
you use
oh this you can't do this glitch anymore
or this like uh skip right
foreign
as a twitch streamer
you guys watch Twitch
you guys YouTube only
you should name your character Squidward
his name is Ned Flanders
I'm dead
man
just kind of scary
got here
worthless
no yeah nah
uh YouTube only
anyone else thinks shibiri is unsettling
oh yeah
what the
I don't know if I've ever been here
I kind of always just run through this
area
lightning great bolts
leave me alone
oh you're a moderator on Twitch gotcha
other than that you stick to YouTube
I feel you I feel you
okay
have
I forgot that's where uh normally a
death route would be not a death route a
uh seed bed curse
that's right that's right
ow
God okay we're good
[Music]
oh
oh hello what are you
orange robe Queen's robe
it's a lot of Robin
man is that who replaced the archery
Avatar wow
probably a lot more we could look at in
there
let me go this way
why does shibiri take Euro's body is
there a reason probably needed a body
that would be my guess
welcome back I don't know how to say
your name so I just like
have a stroke while I try to say it
hopefully that's okay
this is an upgraded plus two if we can
find a somber 3
we can get it to plus 10. we are only
looking for a somber 3 at this point
hello what are you two doing
what do you think they were doing in the
corner
kind of weird don't you think
kind of weird that they were in the
corner
uh oh
were they making out
I think they were making out
and how could you resist
okay let's see what this is go not an
imp oh God
I should just kill the amp
holy [ __ ] I hate amps
okay we're down here now guys
this is not good
really went South
get out of here
come into my hallway
that is a very strong wolf
I don't like this somber
three
three
one Rune ghost flame torch that's kind
of cool
uh what's gonna spawn over here
magic Grease
nothing we care about
hi Glenn how are you oh hang it awesome
foreign
we have a lot of runes to use whenever
we really want
I am just completely focused on a somber
3 right now
you join the Cod beta I I saw some
gameplay I haven't pre-ordered it just
because
I don't want to pre-order Call of Duty
but from what I've seen
Cod looks really good is anyone else in
the Cod here
like Modern Warfare 2 from the gameplay
that I've seen looks great
I don't know much about Warzone 2.0
though from what I saw with that I was
like oh I don't know if I like those
changes or not
um
how to get infected he was flying
because I'm clearly that good at the
game you know what I'm saying
never understood the appeal of cod uh
it's just like addicting
like fun gameplay
like you don't have to think very hard
you know
that's how I see it
let me open this
yep
this may have been a mistake
foreign
hi
foreign
how am I getting out of this oh I'm not
that's the answer I'm not
damn it
why do you like cod though for the
reason as I just said
I really like Call of Duty I've gotten
every single one
okay we have plenty of runes I'm not I'm
not too worried about missing out on
runes there I kind of got lost in the
sauce down there
let's go the normal route
let's grab this another Rooney boy
yeah cold War's story was okay I didn't
dislike it
I was not a fan of the multiplayer
that's for sure
oh that's a big boy
Lord rune
Sage's cave
we'll get there we'll get there
we're just kind of we're kind of just
going you know we're going through the
game
of course my girlfriend to pre-orders so
I could play it on PS4 nice
foreign
better marry her bro
she pre-orders Call of Duty for you
merrier immediately
what's your favorite Souls game it's
between Dark Souls 3 and bloodborne for
me personally
and then Elden ring is in third behind
those two
crab timing
oh I got a medicine Peddler's Bell
bearing
okay
let's go let's go let's go let's go
let's go what the [ __ ]
are you kidding me
what what is this [ __ ]
nope
nope that's a big fat nope
is he gonna shoot a laser at me yep here
we go
ow that hurt
are we
it's wool new
crew
all right all right all right all right
who is that
no
no
no oh
she just killed the bat
no no
I like that though
this randomizer never wants me to finish
he gets healed he heals
oh no
let's go
I'm actually not bad against Melania
Melania was the Elden Lord all along
chat
it was her
foreign
oh God
oh God
oh God
the room is so small
all right
like I said
the room is so small
foreign
oh that was me
[Music]
I didn't hold it
it's something
[Music]
he's doing that [ __ ] where I think she's
gonna do the waterfall
foreign
oh God
nice nice nice
stop it
the first Eldon Lord
somebody tell vati and smoke
Melania is the first Eldon Lord
okay I think we can only do physical
you need a bobber head
back up
[ __ ] hell
I'm scared of the waterfowl
there it is run
do you think the pillars can stop her
foreign
blade of mikola
and I am the first Elden Lord
where is there a hole in here
there are holes in this room
calm down
where here
oh you're right you think she can jump
in there we'll play her over here
it's gonna be hard to get the right
timing for it but
it's potential for this
hello
this is really hard yep [ __ ] this is
weird
that might be our only play
uh because this this area is way too
small for her waterfowl
I think you even the pillars would stop
her waterfowl
or wouldn't stop it
looks like she's weak to frost though
foreign
no I had no stamina
I had no stamina
[Music]
absolutely no stamina
that'd be weird if this hits her okay I
did nice let's go
fall off [ __ ]
I don't know guys
this is like our fourth or fifth attempt
hear it
uh it doesn't look like she goes High
Enough
it would have to be on her first jump
right
dude
foreign
second phase I think that'll be in an
entirely different area
that'll be an entirely different area if
it goes with how the rest of the bosses
and their second first and second phases
have been going
melania's second phase will be in a
totally different area
God damn it
dude that attack is so annoying
the timing of her doing that sweepy [ __ ]
is so incredibly hard to dodge at all of
them
foreign
Jesus
calm down
she gets up so quick
foreign
[Music]
she could do it right now I think her
health bar is too low
foreign
yeah yeah
there it is
that's really unlucky
[Music]
we lived
foreign
this is a great sword
it's the best weapon we got guys
thank you
yeah when she it's so hard to tell when
she's gonna stagger
she's pretty susceptible to uh
isn't she
I don't remember [ __ ] we're also not
near anything
I'm gonna keep trying this
foreign
foreign
nope
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
she input reads this attack
yep
that's exactly where I want you
come on
there you are
bam
[Music]
see that's what I wanted her to do
my character didn't jump man
why am I here why okay
there's no reason for me to be here just
because I fell okay
I'm gonna try that
wait I have to use
uh
have to use this
why am I down here though
this is so far away
now I gotta get past this guy again
yeah I gotta test stuff here
it'll probably just lead to being like
yeah we need to come back later
foreign
wow that's
like are you literally [ __ ] kidding
me
oh
I thought it might do the thing
like I was near the statue
come on that's so annoying
you guys should tell me to go to the
sewers again
I couldn't tell if you wanted me to go
to the sewers guys
leave me be leave me B leave me b
okay you
not exactly what I wanted
yep he's dead
job
he's dead
something I guess it's not very good
wow
wow
my mimic isn't upgraded at all so that's
kind of what I expected
okay that can be a waterfowl I think
I think
does this make me move forward
I will cheese you to the end of time
[Music]
you [ __ ]
[Music]
did it give me Statue Of America why is
it not doing it now hello I gotta run
all I'm going to the sewers
it was doing it before
no I don't have the Blasphemous blade
it doesn't randomize where you spawn
feels that way right now though
I mean we technically have a lot of
levels saved right now like we have so
many runes that we could pop
that I just haven't yet because I want
to make sure we can upgrade
once we get a somber three
holy you guys are really backseaty today
just let me play enjoy
calm down I'm not gonna get every item
stay over there
give me
not worth
where are you going
that's not a door is it
cool
I have been looking for a somber 3 for
this that is true
ow
let's get this thing now
this is kind of why I didn't want to do
it but here we are
come on
well that's a lot of runes
it's an item right there too
foreign
Everything is randomized Everything
we also have to get every single great
rune
before we can go to the end of the game
why am I lost down here right now is
there a door over here
oh there is okay
I think we have a few of those we have
Lords runes and Newman's runes like we
have a ton
an absolute ton hello Alexander
yes any uh any enemy can drop a great
Rune where did we find one of our great
runes I think it has to be from a boss
fight actually like the way I set it up
so we'll just have to test out like
every boss fight
but it can't just be like laying on the
ground
in terms of the great runes I mean
everything else is random
I mean technically that's still random
smithing seven I don't think there's
anything we want over there
or anything on the ground
leave me alone this is gonna be chaos
what did I say
chaos
[ __ ] all y'all
we can't even go through
jelly
oh my God
let me go let me go let me go
I I can't move
what do we do
hello
yesterday was going to be my last day
doing this but chat like was so adamant
about doing it again let's go in here
see what's going on over there
we could try and fight radagon again in
the noble area the godskin noble
Cisco through here there's a lot of
items in this cave
let's give that a try
[Music]
yeah I could probably do that Mabel
I'm being very stingy right now
I haven't been to reichard's Arena we
have fought both variants of Reichard in
one
though
so I have no idea who's gonna be there
okay this has a lot of hidden walls and
items and stuff
is this Sage's cave
I don't think it's called that is it
I don't know exactly where Sage's cave
is
this is
oh
oh thank you
come on man
nothing there
we got a chesty boy
a letter from volcano matter I think we
have all of those
so we could do that
hmm that could be interesting looking
for a potential no that's a flower
okay
I have markets
Jackal I believe
we
need
oh no
hmm
any of these
is that an ant
yep
that sure was an ant
oh
the dung eater's cool I like the dung
eater
thank you for falling
nope please no oh
I want to see what's down here but I
don't want to fight that thing
we gotta check
[Music]
have to
he he's plugged he has no idea what to
do down here
smithing four
mushroom break this thing for me chief
ethane four
all right
God I don't like fighting these guys
they're so annoying
maybe you'll drop something
yep you'll drop blood loss as I walk
back into it as well can I break these
myself
yep
yeah
I have I have so many of everything
except a somber three
uh right before you fight magborn maker
and get jumped by landsex
oh I see what you're saying
so like the area you'd go up to
yeah yeah we could go there that's a
good idea
you're right
like the other way I'd get to Altus
plateau
what did I just hear bro
can I hurt the bear from up here by
doing this
well now it doesn't matter
what else was that
okay we need to get out of here like
right now
we need to go go go
yes the shops are randomized as well
and even with all the Bell bearings we
have we still don't have a somber 3.
what if it was randomly omitted I would
cry
I would cry
you're always late
Sub-Zero
I've been streaming for like an hour and
a half
what are you
Sanctuary Stone
[Music]
okay uh that just looks like every bad
bit of business I could potentially have
foreign
I'm scared
grab and run
not worth it in the slightest and I'm
dead
okay we just have the troll Digger to
deal with
I'm cool with this
what up brother
Fame music for this boss fight by the
way
imagine we get down here and it's radon
or something
God I hate your attack
easy peasy
Beast blood
damn it
all right I don't think we can go in
here because we
which great runes do we have
can I see from here we have radons and
we have godrics
go back to Doc godrics
are you gonna do a lore randomizer like
yesterday you mean like just talk about
lore at the end
I mean maybe that just kind of happened
naturally I didn't plan it or anything
okay we can't go in there
um where do we go now
not there
this is uh reichard's Divine Tower let's
go to that place you were telling me
isn't it like through here
yeah what's better godrics or radon's
great Rune I guess it doesn't it's like
preference let's um let's go to the
round table and sell all this crap like
maybe maybe we can upgrade our mimic
like that would help a lot
I haven't checked into that at all
so let's try it
you think godrics is better
no no no
I need to do better than this
this will never kill a god
can do better than this
it needs to slay up bloody God
man America [ __ ] him up huh oh what up
Teflon how are you
Okay
so
holy guys we have a lot of rooms okay
two three
four
three
four three
four two
just a cool quarter Mill
just a cool quarter Mill
we gotta talk to rodurika don't we
greetings Roger Rica
this isn't this around tape I never knew
although I'm still
I'm still looking I'm still looking for
my purpose
okay level up we have 10 levels to book
around with what do you think we should
do
I feel like we need more health
Frank we were leveling intelligence
as well
for a while we do not have the ability
to respect yet
I think I just want to do Vigor and
strength until we can like figure
something out
just have to wait and see
okay now I have to talk to him
Raleigh could have done more stamina but
I I don't think leveling stamina is
really worth it
you get a lot of stamina in this game
oh roderica
changes
yeah this will work with strength
you have any other weapons you can
upgrade I mean okay so let's see I I
wonder what we could upgrade
we have plenty of ones plenty of twos
plenty of Threes plenty of fours
plenty of fives plenty of sixes plenty
of sevens and plenty of eights but we
have nothing past leveling a regular
weapon past eight
um which is all we need actually right
that'll that'll reinforce it to Plus 24.
which could potentially be good
um
what do we got
plainburg great sword malakat's Black
Blade big blade rivers of blood
wind blade
derpent Hunter
Hannon we really haven't gotten that
many weapons
I need 12 from each that's right
I think we just we have to wait till we
get the somber three
that that changes the game for us
completely
earlier what the blacksmith said
guys rivers of blood is not as good as
it once was I don't think it'll help us
that much
um I believe we just get the
remembrances back
no I haven't read berserk
yeah we found Melania
yeah
we found her
I had your own it's it is still good
you're not wrong
okay
I don't know if I want to do the flame
Burge
I got some in my mind right now like the
weapon we have right now is extremely
good
okay now you're here
foreign
okay
we have one
we don't have it too
um let's see if we can buy a ghost glove
wart number two
let me see what we got
we have a three
four five six yep
see if we can buy it
just
ghost glove work too excellent
we got that now
we did not get the somber 3 yet we are
still looking
two three uh now we need runes
which is amazing how I could even say
that um there's a lot of [ __ ] we could
probably sell right
to lay out your own
like I don't know
we're never going to use this again
is even gonna get us to where we want
no I'm never gonna use these
I might use these
it's not worth it
did I have a bell to give
that's right we can go check
he'll Grail no
we have not killed Grail could we
it's a lot of runes
offer a bell bearing
I don't think
yeah not gonna help us a ton
we can go check rank as well we could do
that
let's go check him out
does he sell stuff off the rip because
actually we have um I wonder what he'll
give us because we have some death route
so we should check that
we might have like two or three death
route to give down
I have not opened the seal downstairs
I have not
wait who's here
oh okay that's not as bad
we get the same amount of runes for
killing these guys so we should probably
kill stuff here if we can
I don't know if we want to kill grank
if you're asking for me to die that's
pretty much the same thing
I guess I have one I thought I had two
or three
oh my God oh my God no way it happened
it freaking happened oh my God
it actually happened
wow
that was random
I'm killing this Avatar out here we're
gonna get the get the runes from that
then GG
well unless I die first
foreign
oh my God I do nothing
[Music]
maybe maybe we don't
maybe we don't
we actually have it man what are we
gonna kill though
we gotta kill stuff for runes this is
why I want to save the runes man
[ __ ]
I don't want to wait for the frost
that'll take forever
watch now all we're gonna get is somber
threes just everything I pick up is
gonna be a Saundra three
that might be a somber three Bell Berry
hahaha
actually might be a somber 3 ball
bearing
I think all dragons are replaced by
other dragons yeah
that was a part of the mod
Mausoleum oh true good call let's do
that
what's the easiest Mausoleum didn't we
already do the mausoleum here I think we
did let me check
yeah dragons will always be another
dragon
yep already did that one
yeah I'm glad I'm continuing too I was
surprised you guys have been enjoying
this this much
we get like decent viewership every time
I do it so I appreciate it thank you
okay
um where is another one where is another
one
ah you're right down here huh
or else the roots go here
okay
I'm late to everything you don't have to
be here man you can watch it whenever
you want that's the beauty of uh
what we do right
it after I'm done it's uploaded
immediately to the channel and you can
watch it
that he's hurting his own guards I love
that
oh wait I have to go up on the branch
I forgot
live is better well that's true
you're not wrong
do I grab this
the answer is yes I do
this is kind of terrifying right here
hey
what the heck is this
I thought this was a mausoleum right
here for a second that was weird
um there's a tree Sentinel there instead
I haven't beaten them though
let's get this boy down
we did obtain the somber 3 about two
minutes ago
okay he's done
last time I was up here it knocked me
off
there we go
yeah everyone just Spam L for anyone
who's watching this not live
did not use the rot goddess and didn't
yeah let's we just need one okay
back to the Round Table
like imagine if you were watching this
live it'd be so much more fun but
instead you're getting spammed with L's
LOL
thanks for watching
okay I I want to see what it has as well
now the I believe I looked at the Elden
remembrance
four over here
now to become okay don't spam don't spam
I just wanted you to say it one time
thanks for the short sword thank you
okay
no I did look at this before I'm dumb
okay
let's pop it
we can go to another one
time to upgrade
the poker
it's time
finally well about to lay out your own
you guys ready for this one two three
four five six
I don't have a nine
off topic where's Joy
um
he's somewhere in here
I thought I had a nine
it's because I can buy it right that's
right
that's why we didn't even think of it
because I can buy it
yup yup yup
just
uh it was one of these
five
no
it's number two
nine
that's right let's get it
now off to defeat
Melania the first Elden Lord
well I took the ball head off and then
everyone got mad at me
plus 10 death poker let's get it
did I upgrade my mimic
yep
oh she is in trouble
he is in big trouble right now
we got a pretty decently upgraded mimic
a plus 10 that's poker
I mean
this Coulda this could end the game
depending on how good this is
you know what I'm gonna do
that's right
yep we're gonna go kill the Gargoyles
we're gonna kill go kill radagon we're
gonna kill Melania here
I feel it now guys
this is it
this is it
I have a uh
I just have my mimic hold
the uh
like potentially my mimic could use Rock
sling
to stagger her
I hate you
try that on the next attempt because I'm
probably dead here
[Music]
it's time
beautiful there it is don't kill him
why did she go after me
at least I have the steak this time
I didn't think she'd go after me man I
didn't run away
okay hold on let me give my mimic
this
just in case he wants to use
that
right okay
she just switched up mid fight literally
the getting good must commence
hey distracted
foreign
a corner
I love that actually
beat her up
oh God
okay
good enough
she just decimated my mimic though
like we were bullying her and she just
said no
okay this is all a skill fight now
though let's go
how did that kill the mimic because it's
waterfowl and it's ridiculously
overpowered
she stood up for herself
she did she did do that
kind of proud of her
[Applause]
let's go
now it's all skill diff
she could actually do it now
I didn't have stamina
uh oh
foreign
I know it's been discussed do you guys
think melania's waterfowl dance is fair
I won't complain about it
but God damn
there's the rock sling
foreign
there it is
that sucks
and my mimic gives her health back
foreign
wear off
foreign
why did she step back what the [ __ ] okay
they can all be dodged at a distance
does that mean it's fair though
fair I might not use the mimic
like no joke
probably okay to have right here
nice
we just demolished her
well this is the one if it's gonna
happen
clearly
bye
no she does transition
are you kidding me
are you serious
no way
there's no way
I thought she'd be in a totally
different area
foreign
[Music]
you crazy woman
foreign
[Music]
this could be one of the worst rooms for
her to be in
I'll try one more thing
hello hello
thank you
I like that I'm a big fan of whatever
the [ __ ] just happened I love that that
was great please do that again
I have no idea what just happened
no
I got staggered
I I think I can
I think I can beat her stage one without
the mimic obviously and then when she
goes in the stage two I can try the
mimic and it might help
we literally have to get lucky in stage
two to get her uh like just bully her
straight up just bullier
hi Fitzy
foreign
down
and we got lucky with the waterfowl too
damn
that sucks
dude God dang it
if one more [ __ ] person tells me to
use rivers of blood
I'm gonna poop my pants
I'm just gonna poop and I'll tell you
and it'll smell
feet feet feet
a metal
you get sushi
oh looks like I'm pooping my pants
I have a plus 10 deaths poker [ __ ] your
rivers of blood
cool
I mean not really but cool
come on
foreign
you can't do multiplayer when you're
modding
just didn't think that would hit me
I don't know what it is about that sweep
attack she does where she goes bang bang
bang bang I just don't like it
like I know to Dodge in but I still
don't like it this one right here I
don't know what it is about it
it's just like weird timing
nice
foreign
okay
foreign
that was so unlucky I mean we have to
get lucky here in in one way or another
there needs there's some form of luck
Happening Here
group's Dodge rolling by increased
damage but increases damage taken
I've never even seen this Crucible
feather
raises attack power with lower equipment
load
I mean I was using this this isn't bad
tell radagon to call me
this music fits her really well
the room does not but the music does
I knew it you stinky
foreign
stop doing jump attacks there because
sometimes she staggers and sometimes she
doesn't
depends on her attack
foreign
it's like a [ __ ] slap when she does
that
come on
come on no come on bro
what what
the what
no way
unlucky
I've seen animes but I don't like watch
them
I don't watch any right now
it's so unlucky I'm in that wall
foreign
okay okay let me stab you and run away
let me stab you and run away
run run he's gonna do it
thousand percent
I'd be very surprised if she didn't
I'm surprised
I am now surprised
and now I'm [ __ ] if she does it I'm
dead
breaker breaker
I I'm a legend
I'm amazing
that's incredible that I'm alive
foreign
oh my God
someone called let me solo her
he was actually in chat the other day
calm down he's going off because her
health is low of course
foreign
what oh God that was so confusing
we need to get out of here
go go go go
you start with that
you
both are
get a mimic
okay I don't want him holding uh Rock
sling there I don't think that would
help
oh it doesn't matter
I am I'm gonna take it off though
okay damn it
we're we've we've made it
it's possible guys we can do it
foreign
that was my bad
I smell it anyone else smell it
that's right you hoe
I I'm just dumb that was stupid I
panicked
that was really good though
that was dumb I'm stupid and I panicked
and that was my fault
smells like poop because I poop my pants
because you guys told me to use rivers
of blood
and I said next time somebody tells me
to use rivers of blood I'm gonna poop my
pants and I did
I did exactly that
oh she's aggro
stop moving for a second
that's
I didn't think she'd do it
I can freaking do this though I feel it
it's just gonna take a lot of gamer
energy you know
I tried to do the thing
I didn't realize how low I got her
health that fast
we need another epic gamer moment
exactly cam just like with Moog
where the chat spams me suggestions and
I completely ignore them and keep
slamming my head into the wall with the
exact build I have
foreign
um and she's being weird
I feel it I smell it I smell it I smell
it
cut it out okay this would be fine
dang it
of course
this is okay
it's fine
I don't think your health is low enough
actually
how it is yup
I love that staircase
that staircase is amazing
[Music]
right into it
close
weird time for a grab
come on staircase
stairs did not help that time
this is getting bad
she's like as aggressive as she is in
stage two
yeah that was just bad
yeah I think she has to be like near the
staircase and on her way down on the
first attack if she hits it then it
stops her but if she's past that then it
doesn't
foreign
she didn't get staggered
or propped
this is bad
oh what the why does she do that
she'll like dude I've never seen her
backstep like that so perfectly
still possible I feel it
we're getting some pretty bad runs here
but
can be done
if only I didn't Panic that one time
dang it
nope I don't take breaks
I'm a gamer not a [ __ ]
I have never been able to do that
I have not once been able to do that and
have it work
I just didn't think she'd do it that
fast I came out so quick
you think I have time to throw a rock
sling at her when she does it the
waterfowl
I don't think so
I doubt it
foreign
there we go good good
I really thought that proc would wear
off
it did not
nice
she's walking like she wants to do it
if you know what I mean
[Music]
just the fact she can
yep
dang it man
[Music]
that was going so well until she just
like I'm gonna do it twice like really
quick
foreign
for stage two
yeah I think she was too far away from
the stairs there
I think
[Applause]
I did not wow both of those hit me huh
[ __ ] you
yeah if I spawn my mimic before her
stage two my mimic's just gonna walk
into it and die
It's gotta get good
that's it
hot I
feel like I do the same thing
and I still get hit from it sometimes
that's fine dude
[ __ ] you
foreign
[Music]
you guys think I I think I saw someone
in chat say it do you think her
aggression scaled with Godfrey
she's obscene she's insanely aggressive
scared of her doing it
just gotta wait
no healing
foreign
can't get too crazy here man
why are you looking at me
he's still looking at me bro
I thought she'd hit the [ __ ] pillar
man
it's clearly possible
I thought she'd get stuck in the pillar
dude so I just went for it
this Arena sucks for her
foreign
I can also change up my healing too I
have way too many FP Flats
I just realized that
how many runes do we get for this fight
I just don't want to run back the Run
back's annoying but I guess I only have
to do it once
I think I need like two FP Flats
NK
can't even level after this
last
you thought you guys think seven three
or seven eight two
70k really
I think eight two
yeah maybe in like new game
we can do this though we got her like
halfway or a little bit past halfway in
stage two I can't believe she goes to
stage two I really did not expect that
really
come on baby
we can do this
surprised I'm alive
hold on for a second
I I think I always have to let her do
the first move there
that was just a bad start
he drops 8 000 or 480 000 runes
it's 80k
do you do we really get 80 000 runes for
this fight are you sure
I do not remember getting that much from
it but I don't I'm not I don't remember
foreign
just goes ham sometimes
foreign
she's going it crazy
foreign
[Music]
come on
you [ __ ]
now it's been too long like she could
just pull it out whenever
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
nice
foreign
foreign
there you are
can we even get far enough away to heal
in this
her she's like more aggressive than I've
ever seen her
man
this is harder than the Moog fight for
sure
this is insane
ah
this arena is just too small
you know it's not where she's supposed
to be but
it's pretty obvious
I mean I per like a lot of people are
say that waterfowl is fair or like
it's not that bad
I I personally don't think it's fair at
all
it's the only thing I think about in
this fight for the most part
which makes it not as good of a fight as
it can be
to me
you know this Arena doesn't make it
better but I mean I I do not like that
attack at all
[Music]
[Music]
yeah it's the it's actually the only
thing I don't like about the fight I
think the rest of the fight is awesome
just that attack I don't even know I
don't understand how people don't think
it's [ __ ] I really don't
maybe they just want to be cool and be
like I don't mind it I'm really good at
dodging it or whatever
it's like
I don't like things that are pure luck
I don't think there should be like luck
involved
[Music]
so you can also just pull it out of thin
air
like if the attack was just it took her
longer to load it up it would be fair if
there was a larger tell for her to do it
it would be fair
just her being able to eat that thing
out of nowhere even while being hit is
such dog [ __ ]
it makes the fight bad
because I'm just running around waiting
for her to do it it's such [ __ ]
foreign
I don't think this is possible
I mean we
we just have to get insanely lucky with
her aggro
which is possible but just
I don't know what it is
like if you could run up to her before
she pulls it out and hit her one time
with anything
and she would break out of it it would
be fair
I know you can throw like a pot at her
but I don't want to be able to like I
don't want to have to go and craft [ __ ]
to fight a boss
foreign
yeah it's the hardest boss in the game
Trey fall off
or breakthrough whatever
what
that's such [ __ ]
nah I'm not fighting her this is such
dog [ __ ] that's
dumb she just did it twice in a row
get out of here with this [ __ ] fight
melania's fight is so bad it's so bad
I'm sorry
anyone who says this fight is fair in
any way is just a [ __ ] fanboy
is broke
where can we go instead we're going to
the school room
broken fight unfair fight
just dumb
the fairest of All fights
just get over it
okay buddy
we already have somber 3. we we have our
weapon to Plus 10.
I'm stuck on his leg
foreign
yeah mimic here is probably the play I
didn't even think of that
just the fact I'd rather do this fight
than Melania really says something
melania's fight always puts me in a bad
mood it always is [ __ ] every time I
try to do it
try not die right at the beginning
foreign
's fighting the stuff outside of the fog
wall bro
cool
there's just like so many random people
who just like always say that melania's
fight it I I don't get it
it's like 50 of people think yeah we can
beat this this is fine 50 I'm still on
Millennia I'm still angry about that
fight
I I don't know how anyone looks at that
fight and says it's fair
but I'll stop bitching about it now
you either gotta be a hundred and level
120 have rivers of blood
grow [ __ ] [ __ ] at her
thank you
there you go you used an overpowered
weapon the blossom display to beat her
in eight tries congratulations
that doesn't negate the unfairness of
the fight
oh come on
thank you
I can't even tell what's happening
anymore
there we go
okay
good job mimic
what is the range on that man
where are you getting the Blasphemous
play whatever you guys are going to say
whatever the [ __ ] you think it doesn't
even matter
the black like where are you getting
that from the Blasphemous blade is
ridiculously good
it what whatever
God I'm mad I'm actually angry
I don't get angry very often anymore
I'm tired of this argument of like
Melania being fair or whatever it's such
a dog [ __ ] conversation
when they know they know when they say
that she's fair that she's not and they
just say it to be annoying
I'm why would I take a break while I'm
streaming
[ __ ] does that mean
like I'm live you want me to leave for
10 minutes
sorry I'm mad
I didn't mean to be mean
tired of these comments man
foreign
[Music]
wow
the game isn't supposed to be fair
hold on
we got a [ __ ] robe
I just read halfway through that fight
the game isn't supposed to be fair like
then it's not a game
whatever
no I'm saying that even when melania's
in her normal Arena and I'm level 100
she's still [ __ ] I know we're doing
a randomizer I'm talking about her in
general
at least we can see what Ronaldo is
okay I can't tell if you're being
sarcastic like
when you're a text
on a screen
you need like a Kappa we need a Kappa
emote
yes yes I'm I'm saying like Melania in
general is not fair in anyone who says
she is is I just don't know how you
think that
I don't get it but you will but be
different
just every Millennia thing that I've
seen is just so that conversation
oh it's hoslow
you're dead
damn
nope the stream has not crashed
yes that's what I was saying too I think
the waterfowl dance is unfair everything
else about Melania is great
I'm just talking about
the waterfowl dance of Melania
you guys saying the stream crashed
it doesn't say it's crashed
I I have not had a boss fight in any
other from software game that is like
that
stream's good okay thank you
thank you thank you
I can't I cannot think of another boss
fight that's as [ __ ] as millennius
waterfowl dances
no no okay so you guys will say
something like if you have Bloodhound
step the fight is fair
you should have any build in the game
with any Ash of War doing any like any
type of build at all and have a fair
experience against any fight
when you have to like go get a
particular item to fight like just
completely Buck your build from what you
were doing before to fight one boss
that's dumb
there's so many ways to fix it and they
just keep her like the way she is
curious who's in here
[Laughter]
for you
myself
ah you're the goat no you're the goat
thank you x to the Sea good to see you
man how are you
how are you thank you very much Drake
corrected your spelling of course he
likes to do that thank you man
no sarcasm or trolling but Melania is my
favorite fight in the game she's hard
but I [ __ ] love it love it waterfall
has to be mastered no mistakes
okay
this fight
what is this gonna look like
oh my back is so hairy oh God I'm
gorgeous
foreign
did I just t-pose
[Music]
this is sad
stop rolling me
where do I have rocks
eat them up
mimic tear Queen of the full moon
so dumb
I'm over it
I'm over it boys
wait now what
I'm confused
I thought it would just end
uh
uh
[ __ ]
[ __ ] get out of here
oh we can do volcano Manor now
weave thy night
they wouldn't even let her finish
God he got annihilated huh holy [ __ ]
where did he flee my sweetings come out
from Wednesday wow
I didn't even have armor on
wow
okay that put me in a better mood my
sweet
you know what I need to get good at chat
and if you have advice on this let me
know
how how do I just not give a [ __ ] about
the dumb things people say
you got advice on that
I would love to just knock here
we got the drawing room key that we
didn't get when we were in here earlier
so that'll be nice
yeah but how do you ignore it
like what do you do
I just like say it in my head that
that's dumb
I worked retail for a long time too did
you read the letter well it was a
different kind of retail but it was
retail
we have no business YouTube today
don't respond
okay
because there's there's some stuff out
here and I'm like man that's one of the
most brain dead things I've ever heard
and I just like I don't know why I can't
stop myself from like getting annoyed
from it man this guy's looking great
Bernal looks sick
you in Heaven's name are you doing here
the volcano manner I don't think I'm
smarter than anybody there's just some
things man not our own kind
I hope you understand the weight of my
words
he looks great huh
perhaps playing that part LED you to
your doubts I wonder but know that the
path you walk is blasphemy and leads
only to a miserable death before you
consider hunting okay sorry I just want
to see him talk to me like that I can't
look at his stuff yet Raya a pleasure to
meet you
I love Raya she's one of the good souls
in this game you know what I mean
he is a good soul
is this one of the letters oh we could
actually do these now let's go
I wonder who these will be I think
they'll just be random NPCs because
dragons replace dragons and NPCs replace
NPCs
you're a better person because you know
you wouldn't do that speak to any
another that way therefore except uh
they're not fully developed yet
ah
any of mentally uh fully developed like
adults out there that I'm just like what
the hell are you talking about
you're you're right I just
man
maybe maybe it's because I have to deal
with like a lot of comments
and I I think eventually it just gets to
my head
when you just see so many of them
all right who this
Sorcerer of a Windhelm
errant
come here Aaron
stop this RP walking
you can't even hurt me
you dead you know I just realized you
didn't even hurt me
we're calling finger remedy in a rune
Arc that was not worth but hey at least
we can get these done and go fight uh
Reichard wherever he may be let's see
what this item is
a Sauber one cool
because I think we have all of the notes
that we need
charge for sacramental bud
um should we try and go beat radagon
actually that would kind of speed the
[ __ ] up
wouldn't it
gotta go through the guest Hall
oh wait no I can go the secret way now
I'm gonna do that that'll be a lot
easier
yeah yeah let's let's try radagon
what's the craziest Elden ring theory
that you believe is real
uh that the person in the Cocoon is not
mikola
I do not have enough evidence to back
that however
so I will never say it again
now they're gonna think I'm brain dead
I think when DLC comes out it's gonna be
uncovered
I don't think the body in there looks
anything like mikola
the picture from Moog
I don't even know if that is mikola
there's there's a lot of weird reasons
it's just like one of those crazy things
that is probably not true
but we'll have to wait until there's
just like more out there
because there's just not enough
oh I couldn't even you're so short
you're so short
a relevant short
ringed finger and a remembrance of the
natural born what a weird place for that
holy [ __ ]
we got a footy boy
yeah we read the twin twin bird shield
a couple weeks ago
yeah they do spawn in with the fire
cannons
very strange
what the hell was that
oh you're stuck in the roof I see
what
I don't have a I think I have a torch
but
I'm just gonna deal with total darkness
instead
okay
I can't see [ __ ] either I promise I just
like kind of know the path
there we go
have a good one femi
all right now we have an easier path to
radagon
because I think we can beat radagon
pretty easily now actually
I like his move set
will there be an elder ring too not
anytime soon
you know another theory I have that
everyone's Gonna Hate
and probably isn't true
is that they're not even gonna make DLC
yeah he's weak defrost
I could use a mimic too but
you chilling we chilling
wait no yeah yeah he's he can be frosted
owie
foreign
he's going nuts
let's go easy
watch we're gonna go elvenbeast now
right guys nope
we got the great Rune of The Unborn okay
that's weird we'll take it though
nice
nope the eldenbeast is gonna be so look
his body's still here
because that's what would happen in the
normal mode
whoa
it even unfrosted
we never see this before
neat
will it disappear when I rest
damn
it's like actually kind of cool
I don't know why I like that stuff
we need more
our endurance is actually pretty low
Dodge
yeah I mean you guys think they're gonna
make DLC right I forgot we talked about
that I mean I I obviously hope they do
make DLC I think there's a large chance
that they don't
and then not a large chance but a chance
and then um
they'll just make eldering two in like
five years
and then uh come out with like a
different IP in the middle
we have three great runes now
oh
no I want to grab that item damn it
why won't they make it there's I mean
it's known that Miyazaki likes making
new games
and not uh
like making a second game or
I guess he's made DLC pretty
consistently but it was only like one or
two
but it would be an awful business
decision so I I think they will I just
don't know when
yeah that's more sequels I guess
too
oh God a bear
oh man
yeah I mean there's no sakuro DLC
and that game won game of the year
with no DLC
yeah that wasn't a real leak what the
[ __ ]
hello
I'm dead
the hell
all right I'm I'm getting to the thing
let's go
artist boss you fight Melania 100 just
because she's [ __ ] dumb
what wasn't published by Bankai
foreign
you [ __ ]
hello
oh boy
that's kind of cool
foreign
godskin Duo devouring serpent
what the [ __ ] do I do about that
what do I do about this
there's no pillars
I think I can Dodge in
yeah I gotta roll through
I was like locked on to something else
and it was weird
have a good one cam
thought I might be able to get it off
yeah I gotta use a mimic
foreign
nice
what's this
nice
there we go
oh thought he was bugged for a second
what what is space two
oh God we gotta listen to the together
have to listen it together
I think it's gonna be radon
oh
yeah
Spirit calling snail
haven't seen radon yet
Cemetery shade
now
my game is not lagging
on PC the cinematics like stutter
y
what is that
who the [ __ ] is that BS champion
get [ __ ]
oh there's gonna be more of them huh
there's gonna be more of them boys
whoa
I need you
stop it
Roger Lord of blasphemy
uh my mimic is dead
the guy has
Bloodhound stuff
this is weird
[Music]
oh
foreign
what a weird combo
oh a sacred tear and a golden seed it's
not terrible and 130 000 runes
no right card audio afterward
yeah that wasn't too bad that was that
was pretty easy
not bad
you can add that add that
cool beans
um
re-levels
I think I should get my Vigor to 40
right
level 80 now
okay where was the other hard area that
we were struggling with
we kind of did everything
I did everything we need to go I mean we
got to fight Melania obviously
[ __ ] millennia
have a good one Tim thanks for being
here bro
oh yeah radon's Divine Tower let's do
that that sounds fun
more so than Melania
go to the sewers you're a lot stronger
now that's that's true we could do that
too
yeah we did Caleb
yo what up bro I haven't seen you in a
few days
how we doing
look at you little baby
oh yeah should we spawn another boss in
tanet's room
wow
nice jump
foreign
foreign
oh no
that was pure luck right there by the
way
better grab Maybe
just roll around in the fire I love it
you're gonna grab
first try
larval's here
94
000 runes
music broke where
oh wait yeah you're right it did
and stone sword Keys somber 5 not worth
it at all
interesting
no that's a boss that's like a dungeon
boss somewhere I'm pretty sure right
the Virgin and one of the Scarlet knots
Scarlet knots Scarlet rot Knights
he's a dungeon okay we got Vigor to 40.
um
I guess we can try Melania again
because that's like our progression path
right now for the most part
not at the same time
I swear I mean we did 100 play through
and I swear that was a boss fight
somewhere
Avatar and grank
hmm
there's two clean Rock nights but not a
knight and a maiden really okay
trying to like I think there was
somewhere
could go this series let me let me try
this
see how it flows if it's bad I will not
bang my head against the wall for too
long
leveled up a good amount
all right Savannah that's where you get
the golden Scarab helmet
okay
weird I guess they just like mixed
together
[Music]
already not a good start
hello
my character is not running
foreign
that didn't work
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
we have to get to Fair Missoula First my
guy the new place to do Saints
we fought plaster Deus Ex at the
beginning of the Stream
when uh what was it called Loretta's
area
thought I was dead
[Music]
I just tanked through that huh okay
foreign
oh my God
oh my God
we're out of everything
don't kill me no
no through everything to hit me there
bro are you kidding me
she went through the
foreign
hello
hello
she just
hello
foreign
[Music]
foreign
yes
we'll take some form of luck
foreign
[Music]
foreign
yes
foreign
some bullshit's gonna happen yep there
it is no idea where she's gonna go
yes
lost ashes of War
I am Melania
bladea these nuts
no I just wanted the reward to be cool
it wasn't
Jake you should use rivers of blood
rivers of blood makes this boss easy
peasy I beat her in three tries with
rivers of blood
it was so easy
I didn't I didn't even learn that she
didn't even do she she didn't even do
waterfowl dance
because I used rivers of blood you
should get rivers of blood
no is the answer
with your blood
Hey listen a lot of people beat her with
livers about liver Rivers I can't even
say it normal now rivers of blood oh
Elden Lord bracers hey we got a grape
we got a grape
okay okay
livers of red
[Music]
all right who's this wait who is that
what the heck oh it's just
a very odd place for you to be
positioned
foreign
[Laughter]
what is this
mending Rune of the fell curse
we could fart on the lands between let's
go
dung eater ending let's go
all right guys place your bets who's
this gonna be
this has got to be redone at this point
right
wait can I see can I check
nope
can't see anybody yet
Elaine Melina get in here
what is thy business with these Thrones
graceless tarnished
what is thy business with these Thrones
ah
godric the golden
Rick
the twin prodigious Michelob and
millennia Rick and his twin Rick
General radon General Rick price
R Rick
Luna princess Ronnie lunar princess Rick
willful traitors oh
oh Rick
yeah watch it be Margaret or a morgot we
haven't seen morgot anywhere
just
emboldened by the flame of ambition okay
I'm curious
thank you
find the lame find a lame kind of lame
boo
boom boo
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
this is our first big boo
it's a Reddit moderator
[Music]
I shouldn't have said anything
[ __ ]
oh my God
oh my God
this shall not be forgiven
oh so weird
boo
ow
a raw meat dumpling
oh that's a good Talisman I think
wow we did it guys
you know what I say to the throne boys
[Music]
we gonna poop on this throne
are we gonna get the rolled Medallion I
just thought of that
didn't we already get the rolled
Medallion Way earlier
morgot got fat
I think I already do have it like a long
time ago
old friend I'm Elena prevented the
Thorns you like my hat so I'd Lie To The
Flame I think at this point we have to
beat the game with this hat
nice or we can use this hat
a red mark was still made
let's go let's get the [ __ ] out of here
bro
let's get the [ __ ] out of here dude
you go Albany balcony
yeah the community art is actually
insane
every thumbnail you see if you go to the
description you can find the artist if
you want
and pick this up
neat
we'll take that
all right you guys saying change the hat
or nah
this hat
or this hat
or this hat
change the Hat change the Hat
what a fit bruh
what a fit bruh
blue ball
we're blue balling out here boys
the age of the blue balls
the age
of blue balls
oh God leave me alone are you
I am done with you let me out now please
thank you
and there's a dog
oh nomadic Merchants cap
you gotta see what's over here
oh
God Slayer seal in teresante
foreign
the age
of the blue balls I can't I'm not gonna
stop saying that I'm sorry
there's a pretty important item over
here normally I wonder if it'll be just
as important
yep we're going for blue balls ending
guys
it's official
get the [ __ ] out of my way
now
yeah behind the statue
Confessor armor it's kind of cool
what are you doing dude nothing
neat
um you only have to die in that area so
apparently it's not even the abductor
that aches you you just have to die in
the area
of the academy and you'll go to volcano
Manor
I always thought you had to be
transported
like eaten but you don't have to you
just have to die
which is pretty neat
all right where are we looking now
it's just mountain tops of the Giants
dumb dog
oh
I have the rolled Medallion boys we are
good
hello hello
yeah let's see what this boss is the
what is it usually the queen Omens
sir
there this is a this is a Waffle House
please stop
okay
actually this thing changes doesn't it
come here Gideon
staff of loss
kind of staff is that
boosts invisibility sorcery kinda lame
I'm the lame
yeah it's to our right right here guys
this way
I wonder if we have to have the great
room for it to work
oh
we are here
it's a snail
it's a fell snake oh
it was a fell snail
I'm getting the snail now boys
laughs
where'd you go
there you are
[Music]
DG no re
interesting
imagine me going there and it's like
[ __ ] Rodan that'd be so weird
foreign
[Music]
okay let me hit this just in case we
want to come back find it weird that we
can't use torrent on these particular
Bridges
kind of sucks
yeah we got a cookbook let's go boys
oh yeah we should go check and see what
this is
oops
thank you
sir this is a Wendy's
please stop please stop fighting in our
Wendy's
sorry I was reading a text
followy
getting randomly hyper four hours into a
stream
you know what it is it's because I beat
uh
it's it it's because I beat you know who
Melania I'm like I'm happy now
[ __ ] fights
[ __ ]
okay because I was gonna be worthless
strength of 30. uh uh we can start
leveling into
oh damn my character looks so freaking
cool
other Enya purchase screen greetings
uh
I'm not sure
we need a seven
we already fought plaster Deus Ex
okay where were we we're on our way to
yay dab on eat slab let's go here
the items were not good
I think it's dumb that we can't use
torrent here
I think it's dum dum dum dum dum
man I'm really complaining today huh
foreign
is office of course
but of course
that Super Chat come through stepped
away from the TV
um if you sent one I did not get one
where's the door at I don't remember
there it is
gee
wow a golden ruin one excellent
methinestone six and lightning grease
you sent one uh did not come through yet
unfortunately
hopefully it will kick into gear
but if you did thank you very much I
don't know how much it is but
hopefully it'll come in
we got the homemade South
let's get it boys
we shall see
yeah I believe I know they're working
because we got one earlier
about an hour ago
it says
I have not touched anything so it should
work
if it did go through
homemade spaghetti sauce oh [ __ ]
whoa that actually looks really cool in
here
that definitely fit
what is that is that a talisman
all right what is this boss gonna be
[Laughter]
where are you going
there you are
oh you are scaled as [ __ ]
or weak to strong against this
yeah I don't know how I would do this to
her
and go to mogan's Palace what are you
talking about
foreign
oh it's the item I need huh cool
where do you normally get that
it just teleports me
if I use it
oh you get it from Vari so that's what
you get at the end of his quest I did
that
when the game first came out so I have I
have literally not done that quest in
six months
totally forgot cool good to know thank
you
we found our first tibia Mariner
well thanks guys I appreciate you
start leveling in
um so do I just have to use it to be
teleported there
hoist medallion
okay good to know thank you thank you
interesting
420 000 runes
did we go see what Moog is
see what chivalry looks like
I guess this is Yura huh
looking cool buddy
oh yeah we got this weapon to plus 10
now
you guys want to go
so I just have to use the item right
this item
audience with Moog will be granted one
day
I mean it can't hurt
make chaos
take
the world
oh it takes me all the way here oh
that's kind of cool
it's Mogan time
that's a nice item
foreign
or something dumb also how the [ __ ] are
we gonna get through here I just thought
of that oh no
oh no guys this could be really bad
although not all of them attack right
yeah
they still have the same aggro holy [ __ ]
this is weird
leave me alone
he is Hood excellent oh God
police
give you a hand
everybody stay calm everybody relax
somber seven oh okay we can level up
another weapon if we want
trying to get intelligence up there so
maybe we can level something else
eventually
just keep running guys don't even look
welcome back Krusty
I can't see
I can hear though
you kind of hurt brother
[ __ ] you
oh dear
Bell bearing
ew these are all trash
I'll buy this though why
hello
you stay right over there buddy
nah run arcs aren't that helpful
I don't want to kill him I don't like
killing the merchants it makes me feel
bad
der than his usual items yeah
okay
I'm very curious to see this is
they come back over there later
I do not want to aggro all that right
now
we already fought placidusex so it can't
be placed to do sex
can't see yet
skip
it's [ __ ] morgot Lord of blood this
is actually cool
he could have gone this route
damn ow
L
is mine and mine alone
well
whoops
okay let's use a mimic this time
he does use a blood flame weapon
he's scaled the Moog for sure
but he doesn't heal
so that's that's fine
I think that's what made Moog originally
extremely hard was that he healed
and then his stage two is insane
foreign
please don't heal
[Music]
didn't heal
come on mimic hit him
[Music]
why why still me bro why still me
you got people trying to hit you
got him
what
what
I
we got another great room boys
more Gwen
yeah we destroyed him we are extremely
strong now by the way
extremely strong
he dropped his brother's rune
oh shh
that I thought that fight was really
interesting in this Arena because like
lore wise he could have gone that route
it's very that's pretty cool to me
that was pretty easy
um if I remember right a merchant sells
one half of the Halo tree
isn't that right
yeah we beat Melania
wait what I feel like morgot would be a
good boyfriend like I could fix him
oh no
it's like legendary item in the chest
Maggie mogan's Palace
here let me let me get a Grace and we
can
foreign
want to fix me never mind
I'm not that down bad
ain't no giant here
please help
I got some anger issues okay
my anger issues are not any worse than
anybody I've seen
I wouldn't even call him an issue I
think I get mad at things that you
should get mad at
I'm perfect that's not true
come here Gideon
the felly Lou puppet
yeah the godskin noble fight for morgot
was a bit of a letdown but at least it
was easy and we weren't stuck there for
like forever
what why are things just dying over
there
foreign
yet guys
Rick
we have yet to see Rick
I really hope he's the Eldon beast fight
I really hope he's the eldenbeast fight
that would be cool
we have not seen did we see godric guys
I don't think so
not possible sorry why not
he's one of the bosses
I believe the fire giant was the last of
the Giants yes and we kill him
bosses are categorized I mean I changed
a lot of settings so
the thing with with the mod I saw it was
um
if they have
a boss health bar at the bottom
then it counts as a boss
and can be anywhere where there's a boss
health bar
you're the spirit collar snail cave
um
I feel like there's gonna be a lot of
enemies down there
foreign
bosses are major bosses
this godskin Noble count as a major boss
because that's where we just fought
morgot
that's hot
[Music]
I want to see what's in this Abigail
foreign
it's a major boss on the Divine Tower
really
not in the
um
in the church a volcano Manor
all right we got here
oh God this fight is on yeah it's
another Abigail fight that makes sense
this fight's really hard if I remember
right
[Music]
foreign
was right
there's no face
blind Tower it's Apostle not a noble no
it's a noble
you mean under
not the one under the other one where am
I going why am I over here what the [ __ ]
wait never mind that's right
yeah Electro's insane
I just want Rick to be the last boss
even if it's not possible I'm gonna
believe it to be true
I think Rick's a major boss
foreign
I didn't have stamina
[Music]
holy [ __ ] you're fast
[ __ ]
this was a mistake
got lucky with the dope
that timing is annoying
myself
God damn quit moving
oh it didn't get staggered that time
oh no
nice
[Laughter]
excellent we got a [ __ ] painting
excellent
100 000 though that's big
Priceless painting
I wonder who the fire Giant's gonna be
we need more mind
holy [ __ ] tell me to check the chest in
mowglen one more time
please
I will get to that when I get to it my
dude
Jesus
the Eldon Giant
foreign
just want to get all the way up this
mountain
uh Reichard was already fia's champions
stage two is Fiesta Champions so
technically that means we get two boss
fights here right
oh a scholar cap
I did not know you could even get
a child scholar cap
uh NPCs are random but they're gonna be
rant like they're still in PCS right
okay let's go check this chest
all right
whoever it is it's gonna be a weird
fight with how big the arena is
oh God
not worse at all not even not even a
little bit
not even a little bit
could be eldenbeast and malachath back
to back
we are here
Melania not applying death plight
he was at this church
gonna be like some NPC but I'm curious
what we get out of it
'll just be like a mixed NPC
yeah would Margaret count as a separate
boss
Aryan Knight
thank you
[ __ ]
owned
owned
a lot of Grease that's great
that's amazing
a lot of the stuff turns out to not be
worth it at all but it's still fun isn't
it I
find 18. it's a very odd build that
we're doing huh
also I think I can use torrent in here
so like whoever the hell it is
probably not used to using torrent Maybe
I don't know let's find out
okay it's it's radon it's him dude
cool
cool fire redone
don't shoot shoot at me ow
whoa his armor really glows here man
his armor glows big
well you think you'll launch in the air
oh [ __ ]
I didn't think that'd kill me
you guys think you'll launch in the air
it'd be kind of cool to see him like do
it in a different area
I died fast
I died very fast
he hits hard
this man hit very hard
he re-lights the forge on the way down
thick
what are you doing we're done
let's see it
will the music stop nope wait there's
the Moon
there he is oh [ __ ]
glitch to tell but very cool
owned
bye
all right now oh
I got it I gotta use mimic before this
what a cool combo
what a cool combo man
that's actually awesome I love this this
is better than the fire giant fight
hello
right the gravity sorcery so it it seems
like just just thinking lore wise you
guys notice that the moon glowed there
and it's never glowed there before
radon's coming down from the Moon it
looks like that is cool
because it glows in the normal fight
obviously
that's so cool
oh
I wanted to get them before his
transition
right there
yep
excellent
whoa
get a mimic
ow that hurt oh
he's like glitched out in the sky
[Music]
tune
this is so cool look at the angle
[Music]
I could use torrent
can't Dodge that on torrent
dude he's way too high
damn
foreign
yeah I think I need range
don't kill me
I don't think so rivalry
yeah
damn
all right we need some type of range
so what can we work with here
is Rock sling good against them
whoops wrong thing
I think we gotta do Rick sling yeah
um
let's just go with that for now
can't really think of anything else that
would be helpful there
use the staff of loss or the staff of
the guilty
the scales with int
does less physical damage but I kind of
just want him to
I've definitely put more into enthan
faith
we fat rolling though
no pants
there we go
we could upgrade it
does that really help that much though
I thought it was mostly like what you
level
with spells
does it really help
okay
I didn't think it would
foreign
foreign
have a good one
okay
[Music]
yikes
what
yep we're gonna need to go upgrade that
for sure
damn the range on that bro holy crap
we need more FP flasks too
hello
I thought he just did that
bad timing
this is so cool looking just gotta say
I think I went for I went for that
instead of the repose
okay
definitely need more FP Plus
um we're gonna upgrade what is this oh
my God
God damn that [ __ ]
that nuked me dude
I died all right let's go let's go
upgrade that for sure for sure for sure
I mean I don't have I've leveled mind a
bit but we can have flasks and that'll
be fine I had plenty of FP over left
over
at a healing spell for the mimic to your
ashes
through
well I took you nowhere to lay out your
own would be helpful
I don't think we need it
it's not a bad idea though
right that's uh incantations
okay
would it be smart of me to to level this
what am I doing right now okay
and I use a different staff I need 60 in
to use this
which is kind of all I have right now
48. I mean this this will be fine it was
doing just fine so let's do that
Bang Bang
can't level that much
any more smithing ones let's see if we
can get any
yeah because selling is good we just
don't have the level in the int yet
I have been leveling it though
just
smithing Stone threes if we need them
uh offer
okay
didn't really help
I can only buy one
all right
number three it only has one bro
man dude
I'm just buying the ones that I see
why that sacred tear for sure
then
hey look tree might as well
this is bad
hoping they don't pull a secure on us
and just put out no DLC expansion we
were talking about that a little bit
earlier I think it's I think it's very
possible that they don't wanna
um go further with this I think it would
be a dumb business decision but when
it's from software been all about
business you know
they kind of do what they think is best
most of the time
okay that sucks
I think it I think we can still beat
them the way we are right now though
let's go try again
we just gotta
um change our FP for sure and then I
think we can
I would die if there's no DLC well I'd
hope you wouldn't die
is that be crazy
what do I have like better this so it's
everybody's Faith boost strength
might be better than enhances Dodge
rules for a time yeah
plus allocate
let's go seven four
yeah everyone wants DLC
that doesn't mean it'll happen though
I hope they do
a Michelob DLC is needed I mean they
could just have people wonder maybe
that's what they want is for people to
just not know
they'll make a DLC guys
they will
don't worry about it
it'll happen
oh I'm dead aren't I
don't know what I was thinking there
that was just all bad
why strength because my weapon scales
with strength
it's the only like the best option I
have
ah just when he doesn't meet you right
now
okay I haven't died nevermind
that was entirely my bad
I trust rumsaw
I mean would it ruin your trust if they
didn't make a DLC that they said they
had they've never promised a DLC
we're done
we're done
we're done okay
there we go
probably two-handed
he's trying to Rost like
oh
and he's dead
okay
oh God
nice
nice whoops there we go
I can't see right now obviously
nice
foreign
badge
oh my God that scared the [ __ ] out of me
man
supplies weird
I actually just got jump scared
all right guys it is 5 p.m I think this
will take us a bit to actually beat
we either we are either going to
continue this tomorrow or on Monday
but I gotta go for now unfortunately I
am sorry about that
yeah at first it was cool now it's like
[ __ ] it's still cool it's still cool
it's just hard you know that's okay
um yep we'll be back tomorrow
uh I feel bad for um
somebody did a Super Chat they said and
it never went through that's weird if it
didn't
um
anyway I gotta go I gotta take care of
the doggies because
Bam's out right now
but we'll be back tomorrow at some point
or Monday I usually take Sundays off
just to like kill and not do anything
but we'll see if I feel like going
tomorrow then you'll see it get your
notifications on like the stream
appreciate you being here this is a lot
of fun
and uh I'll see you guys soon all right
thanks for everything
and I'll catch you later
peace and love guys
boy boy boy boy